welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead world beyond full series
recap seasons one and two and you know
the best place to watch the world beyond
is on amc plus click the link in the
description to sign up now and
experience the expanded walking dead
universe our show takes place 10 years
after the start of the zombie apocalypse
so it's in line with the current walking
dead our story begins at a very
successful survivor's community the
campus colony at nebraska state
university the young adults here have
grown up with safe reasonably normal
lives most of them never experience
seeing the horrors outside the walls but
today is a very special day it's
monument day memorializing the start of
the zombie apocalypse and the campus is
getting some vip visitors today from
their allies at the civic republic yes
the people with the three-ring
helicopters yes remember in the walking
dead prime rick grimes sacrificed
himself to save alexandria but he
survived he was found by jadis the
former leader of the trash people who is
in contact with this mysterious
helicopter group they flew rick grimes
away and theoretically he's still
hanging out with them and now we finally
get to meet them this is lieutenant
colonel kubleck of the civic republic
military the crm and these people mean
business now apparently the three-ring
logo represents the alliance of three
big survivors colonies omaha of which
this campus colony is an offshoot
there's also portland but the civic
republic themselves are very secretive
they're not telling their allies where
they're based but they're still allies
and they're welcomed by iris student
council president and a real go-getter
her sister hope though does not trust
the civic republic she's a troublemaker
type has brewed a bunch of homemade
alcohol see the girl's father is a very
good scientist and a few months ago he
went to the civic republic to help them
do science stuff but because they're so
secretive they don't let him have any
communication with his daughters and
hope thinks that's bs but the sisters
are smart and resourceful they've set up
a secret beeper communication with their
father and this night they get a message
oh he's in danger now lieutenant colonel
kublai is trying to build trust with
these girls please call me elizabeth i
really shouldn't be telling you this but
your father is at a research lab
somewhere in new york just please don't
go out on a misguided adventure to
rescue him but if you tell a teenager
not to do something that's exactly what
they're gonna do and so the girls
recruit their fellowship there's elton
the smart goofy nerdy kid and silas the
socially awkward gentle giant and so
they set off on their epic quest to
rescue their father venturing out to the
world beyond now there are two adults on
the show felix and huck from campus
security who once they realize these
kids are missing have to go out there to
try to bring them back and turns out
everyone left at just the right time
because the civic republic slaughtered
the entire campus colony wait why did
they do that we don't get an explanation
but i guess the civic republic really
are the bad guys so outside the walls
our wily group of teenagers encounter
their first zombie who they call empties
iris is feeling real confident cause she
got an a in zombie killing theory but in
practice she fails miserably and these
first few episodes it's pathetic as
these kids make every mistake in the
book they really don't deserve to
survive but they do survive and one
night when elton tells hope about how
the last of a species are called the
endlings our crews got a cool nickname
finally the adults catch up to them it's
like alright kids fun's over let's go
home but iris is on a mission she's not
going back without her father so these
two realize they're going to be stuck
chaperoning this misguided field trip as
they travel our gang encounters a series
of boring non-adventures that could
mostly be solved if they could kill one
zombie but one night there's a shakeup
when someone finds their camp improbably
it's another teenager his name's percy
and he's a real cool dude who's grown up
out here in the zombie wilds iris thinks
percy's the bee's knees but silas is
jealous cause he kinda has a crush on
iris now they're gonna help percy get
his truck back from the guy who stole it
from him but when they get there luckily
he's already dead but wait he's not dead
he was faking yes this was a con to
steal their stuff iris chases after that
rascal percy unfortunately she's not the
most athletic but percy comes back to
save her he's like yeah sorry about the
conning thing you guys actually seem
cool this is my uncle tony who is a
magician and the new coolest character
on the show now turns out this truck
they found is from the civic republic
and in it they found a map to the fuel
depots that only work if you light up
with the screen they try that screen on
their map of new york and now have a
destination it looks like their father's
at a research center at the old cornell
university yeah what's going on with the
civic republic we really don't get much
only a few short scenes at the end of
some episodes basically they are a
massive survivors community based in
apparently a big city and they have
utilities electricity running water even
television so that's cool but when this
guy questions why they massacred the
entire campus colony he sent to a
re-education camp which is never a good
thing also we see that apparently at
this research lab at cornell university
they have a ton of zombies they're
experimenting on yes there's an a there
this goes back to what jada said to the
helicopter that was taking rick grimes
do you have an a or a b theoretically
a's are people that were recently bit
and we can assume they're doing research
on how to cure the zombie virus so back
with the endlings percy continues to
flirt with iris cause she's the first
teenage girl he's ever met silas doesn't
like this though and later that night
someone's murdered uncle tony the murder
weapon was silas's wrench and they find
him drunk as a skunk looking real guilty
yes this season we've seen that silas is
committed to non-violence even against
zombies but once he gets going oh he's
an unstoppable rage monster turns out
his tragic backstory he had an abusive
father and one day he beat him to death
so it's like silas did you kill uncle
tony but he was blackout drunk he
doesn't remember but he's like yeah
probably was me because i'm a monster so
to protect his friends from himself he
leaves the group going off on his own
but elton's his best friend is gonna go
bring him back he's like hey maybe i'll
find my long-lost mom out there but now
all their tragic backstories are coming
out at the same time the night of the
zombie apocalypse iris calls the day the
sky fell because a plane i guess fell on
them but turns out zombies didn't kill
their mom it was another woman who was
stealing their truck and when she
dropped her gun little hope picked it up
and shot that woman elton's parents were
paleontologists which explains why he
has a triceratops horn and turns out the
woman hope shot was his mother when he
showed hope a picture of his mom she
realized the truth now finally tells him
and elton's destroyed but there's an
even bigger secret in the group because
huck is a crm spy and more than that
lieutenant colonel kublic is her mom
apparently her mission is to bring one
of the sisters to the civic republic but
they can't have the whole group coming
so next chance she gets she wrecks the
truck then when some zombies come oh she
injures felix he's gonna be laid up for
a while but hope's impatient she's like
huck my dad needs us let's just go you
and me so huck's plans work perfectly
but earlier she and her sister found the
civic republic code book and
unbelievably were somehow able to decode
it and they discovered the message that
huck is a spy so hope pulls a gun on her
like you got some explaining to do but
hux like hey the civic republic are the
good guys we're working to cure the
zombie apocalypse and we need you hope
because apparently you're a super genius
yes her father's been working on the
cure in fact he has a girlfriend there
one of the other scientists and he told
her about how his daughter hope is
incredibly smart cause like one day she
built a computer or something now super
genius isn't really what i'd call hope
but i guess she did brew all that
alcohol so that counts for something
hope asks a valid question why didn't
you just invite me to come join my dad
instead of setting up this whole fake
adventure and huck's like well that
would have been too easy meanwhile elton
out looking for silas first finds an
injured percy they finally find silas
and percy explains it was huck who
attacked them congrats man you're not a
killer just then though the crm is
closing in and to buy them time to
escape silas goes and turns himself in
then iris and felix catch up to huck
like hey it's over we know you're a spy
hut's like sorry man i hoped it wouldn't
come to this and they have a fight to
the death in the end huck is gonna kill
felix but oh a shot rings out it's hope
who puts the gun to her own head yeah
she pulls a hunger games you need me
alive let all my friends live so iris
and felix are left behind as huck and
hope go to catch their helicopter to the
civic republic it's like congrats hope
you completed the adventure now you get
to come with us the good guys and help
save the world so hope is playing nice
for now but earlier she had a secret
combo with her sister the civic republic
may claim to be the good guys but we
know they're evil we're gonna take them
down so iris and felix continue their
mission and come across an unexpected
character it's felix's boyfriend yeah
we've heard about him knew he went with
the girl's father as his security detail
and now they're reunited so season one
comes to an end with iris and felix
outside hope going inside silas also
going inside but as a prisoner and elton
and percy outside i'm not sure what
they're doing so if season one has
piqued your interest don't spoil
yourself yet sign up for amc plus and
binge through all of the world beyond
season two right now so in season two
hope is flying off to the civic republic
and right away lieutenant colonel
kubleck tells them about how the campus
colony and omaha were destroyed she
blames it on a massive herd of walkers
they call columns and apparently there's
a few super clusters walking around
bigger than we've ever seen iris gets
the news too from felix's boyfriend will
who was asking too many questions about
it so they tried to kill him iris
immediately figures out the zombie
column was just a cover it was the civic
republic themselves who killed everyone
and indeed we get a flashback to see she
is right we don't know why they
destroyed omaha yet though probably they
don't want competition so will made some
friends at a small survivors colony led
by this woman indira but they have an
alliance with the civic republic they
shouldn't be harboring fugitives but
iris convinces him to let him stay for
now and meanwhile hope is finally
reunited with her father dr leo bennett
now we're still not inside the true
civic republic this is their research
facility in upstate new york it's
basically a college where hope meets a
cute guy and they flirt while playing a
dangerous game of jenga and the adults
here are trying to find a permanent
solution to the zombie problem their
hope is to find some way to increase
their rate of decay so they would all
just you know fall apart in a first day
of class hope is like hey i'm kind of a
super genius when it comes to brewing
alcohol have you tried like fermenting
them with yeast and the scientists had
not tried that it looks real promising
so super genius hope solved it in a day
elsewhere elton and percy are out in the
wilds where they improbably come across
a couple more youngsters this girl has
some dumb religious ceremonies she made
up where she plants flowers on the eyes
of dead walkers and turns out these are
indira's kids so they're reunited with
iris and iris didn't know percy survived
he disappeared the night he stood her up
for their date but very soon they have a
second date and are in love and even
elton becomes kind of a ladies man he
hits it off with this girl asha
meanwhile silas was captured at the end
of season one but they don't throw him
in jail or kill him they give him a job
he sent to their nearby culling facility
where every night they make a lot of
noise to attract the zombies and kill
him in mass but they need a plucky crew
of young adults on cleanup duty they use
this like spear twisty thing that silas
gets the hang of real quick his boss
here is this cool dude dennis who
quickly becomes a mentor to silas and
turns out dennis knows another of our
group he was married to huck she stops
going by huck though of course her real
name is jennifer and apparently her long
mission undercover was a punishment
because dennis was drinking on the job
and she covered for him she's like hey
hope sorry about the lying but it all
worked out cause now you're here safe
with the good guys but hope's like yo if
you really care about us prove it take
me to my sister so she sneaks her out to
endear his colony and sisters reunited
so hope's like hey iris just turn
yourself in and come join us it's not
that bad there they have hot boys in
jenga but hope's like what no the civic
republic are the bad guys and she shares
her theory that they destroyed the
campus colony and omaha so iris makes
her own plan first they go find silas
and bring them up to speed then they do
actually turn themselves in pretend
everything's cool we still think the
civic republic are the good guys percy
comes with them by the way pretending to
be elton so now iris is finally reunited
with her father but it's like hey we're
not staying this is part of an escape
plan to get us all out and it's
happening in like five minutes but
meanwhile jennifer asked her mom about
omaha and got a very evasive answer so
she goes snooping and finds proof it was
the military that killed him but it
wasn't just a military operation it was
also part of a secret science project
based right here so the gang decides
they can't leave until they find out
more leaving their getaway driver silas
high and dry he's arrested again he
talks his way out of it though like i
was just looking for the bathroom now
remember the girl's father has a
scientist girlfriend here but pretty
soon he realizes she's part of this
secret operation so they break into her
lab and discover some deadly poison gas
a whole bunch of it they're gonna take
out portland next we eventually find out
the project she's working on is delaying
the reanimation time with the end goal
being to have the dead not come back at
all but she needed to test her formula
on a massive scale so the military came
to her like hey we're gonna wipe out
omaha anyway so they combined her
formula with poison gas killed a hundred
thousand birds with one stone now
jennifer's mom left on urgent business
so we have a new main villain for the
rest of the season it is jadis yes the
leader of the trash people from the
walking dead prime who of course gave
rick to the civic republic we don't
learn anything about what happened to
rick except that he was valuable but as
for jadis she became a true believer in
the civic republic and is part of the
military police hunting down traders
which is awkward for her old friend
jennifer who's currently involved in
treason so with the secret gas sample
missing they questioned dr bennett the
plan was for his girlfriend to be like
oh i just misplaced it but she narks on
him yeah they stole it cause they were
curious but it's all okay now he can
work on the project too jadis is like
sure that works for me in fact you're
the new head of the project because your
girlfriend has not been getting results
and has proven herself a security risk
oh she has her killed this version of
jadis is hardcore but our crew is not
scared into submission they make a new
plan to actually escape for real and
warn portland before it's too late now
turns out hope's jenga boyfriend is the
son of major general beale the top head
of the civic republic military so with
the valuable hostage our crew negotiates
their escape but he makes a break for it
and it turns into a shootout jennifer
makes her move and chooses her friends
over the evil civic republic but in the
fight percy was killed oh that's sad
meanwhile they're about to wipe out
endears colony for betraying him but
some of our crew gets in there to save
the day then silas and elton are
grabbing supplies but their escapes cut
off by the zombies they let here as a
distraction so they come up with a wild
escape plan they're rolling down the
hill in the big globe sculpture okay so
now outside finally our original core
four fellowship are reunited and by this
time they've redeemed themselves from
their complete ineptitude and zombie
killing they'd like kill a lot of
zombies this season so the kids are
going to go war in portland while
jennifer and dennis go into the civic
republic and expose what the military's
done yeah the civic republic military
the crm have been operating with no
civilian oversight but there is a
civilian government who are probably
actually good guys in fact wiping out
the other communities is probably part
of the military's play to seize power
and so this all might lead to a civic
republic civil war but first they need
to destroy the poison gas so dennis and
silas go on a run to find a detonator
meanwhile felix has a big final fight
where he goes full darth maul okay yeah
then jadis comes for her final fight
with jennifer but there's less fighting
and more talking as jadis drones on and
on about how the civic republic is the
last light of the world eventually
though she does stab jennifer but she
was just buying time because she did
have a detonator and jadis barely makes
it out as boom all the poison gas is
destroyed yes huck lied to get dennis
and silas to safety and dennis who's
dying of his wounds anyway is like look
kid the crm's coming the only way for
you to survive is to shoot me and go
undercover with them it's super sad but
silas does it and he's arrested again
the rest of our gang all meets up but
there's one final twist so a walker's
coming for hope and elton sacrifices
himself to save her i take my jacket off
for one minute and look what happens but
they make it to safety and time to
amputate he's gonna live just lessen arm
silas is brought inside the actual civic
republic looks like nice place jadis
apparently has superhuman powers of
insight and knows that his whole thing
was a ruse but she's still gonna let him
join the military she believes that she
can turn him into a true believer as for
her massive failures at the research
facility she manages to blame it on
lieutenant colonel kublic yes it's a
power grab she's getting promoted and
jadis is going to be a real top dog as
for the sisters they say farewell their
paths are taking them in different
directions hope is staying here with her
dad to do science stuff hopefully cure
the zombie apocalypse although it's not
really clear where here is while iris
leads the other youngsters to portland
to warn them about the crm and build a
resistance and that's where our story
comes to an end but we're not done yet
because there's an after the credit
scene in france a mysterious woman boots
up some old hard drives and finds a
video message from dr jenner he's of
course the scientist from the cdc they
meet in the walking dead season one and
apparently this is the french cdc that
he was working with at the beginning of
the outbreak but now our woman's found
by a frenchman with a gun and their
conversation is intentionally very vague
the gist of it it seems is that the
zombie outbreak started right here in
france and the scientists here who are
close to a cure actually made it worse
so the people in france now are hunting
them down now some people say he shot
her in the head it's unclear i don't
think so but in any case she does come
back as a walker way faster than normal
and she is clearly a new type of zombie
that's much faster and violent than
normal what's gonna happen here is the
walking dead gonna turn into the running
dead and how will the world beyond
affect the future of the walking dead to
find out sign up for amc plus the only
place for the entire walking dead
universe season 11 is the final season
of the walking dead and the stakes are
higher than ever right now you can binge
through the first eight episodes part
one of this three-part final season it
sets the stage for a grand finale you
gotta be watching find out how the
walking dead's gonna end plus explore
the expanded walking dead universe with
shows like world beyond and fear the
walking dead the first half of fear
season seven is available now find out
what's going on in texas where things
are getting wild so click the link in
the description and sign up for amc plus
now is the time to dive into the walking
dead universe
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member